Speaker 1: One of the problems that Mehmet Oz
is facing in his Pennsylvania Senate candidacy
is that he's running as a Republican, and yet
he's been pro-choice as far as I can remember
for a really long time. Maybe that's changed.
He previously supported Obamacare. He previously
supported health insurance mandates before turning
against them. And so there were some MAGA people
who were not super big unmet oz. And now Trump
has endorsed Mehmet Oz, and it's all going
completely and totally bonkers. MAGA world melting
down, melting down over Trump endorsing Mehmet
Oz. So let's go first to the clip of Trump's
endorsement. This was we looked at it earlier
in the context of the rally. Here is Trump
announcing to the crowd he supports Mehmet Oz.
Speaker 2: By the way, I endorsed another
person today, Dr. Oz in Pennsylvania.
Dr. Oz himself a great guy. A good man, good
man. Harvard educated. Tremendous, tremendous
career. And they liked him for a long time. That's
like a poll. You know, when you're on television
for 18 years, that's like a poll that means
people like you. But he's a he's a great guy.
Speaker 1: This, you know what's crazy?
The reasons that they dislike Mehmet Oz are
pretty reasonable things like he has a history of
being pro-choice. He has a history of supporting
Obamacare that is making them lose their minds
over Trump's endorsement of Oz. The things that
should disqualify him immediately like the fact
that he promoted quack cures for colds, drinkable
silver. You know, it's indistinguishable from
Alex Jones. They don't seem to have any problem
with that. But MAGA world is melting down. Sean
Parnell, the former Trump endorsed candidate who
had to drop out of the race after an allegation
surfaced from his ex-wife, wrote on Twitter,
I have enormous respect for President Trump. I was
honored to have his endorsement in Pennsylvania
twice, but I'm disappointed by this. Oz is the
antithesis of everything that made Trump the
best president of my lifetime. He's the farthest
thing from America First, and he'd be very bad
for Pennsylvania, right wing radio host Erick
Erickson tweeted. It's like Donald Trump's staff
is sabotaging Trump by convincing him to make
the worst possible endorsements. Breitbart News
is Joel Pollak wrote This endorsement could divide
MAGA in the only way that matters. He could lose
America first conservatives over it, and then
Republican Mo Brooks from Alabama, who's running
for Senate. He recently had a rift with Trump.
Trump un endorsed him, he wrote. This is happening
because Trump surrounded himself by staff who are
on McConnell's payroll and hostile to the MAGA
agenda. Everybody telling Trump who to endorse
in primaries works for the swamp. They played
him again. Roger Stone was on Telegram, writing,
Wait. President Trump endorsed this guy, Town Hall
columnist Kurt Schlichter wrote. It's pretty hard
for me to fully express how disappointed I am in
Trump for endorsing Oz. From Blaze TV, Allie
Beth Stuckey wrote, Wait, is there anything
conservative about Dr. Oz? So they don't love
Trump. They love what they imagine Trump to be.
And when Trump shows what he is, which is he puts
his finger to the wind. He supports people he
thinks will win. He supports celebrities.
He loves celebrities. That's why listen,
what's the similarity between Herschel Walker and
Mehmet Oz? There's not much other than they're
both well known in celebrities based sports
TV, cetera. Trump gets his information from TV.
We should be glad he didn't try nominating
Judge Judy to the Supreme Court because
that's how Trump makes decisions. The real
question is, should Oprah be held accountable
for unleashing Mehmet Oz upon the world? I'm half
joking, but it's horrible. The guy's horrible.
Herschel Walker is horrible. Mehmet Oz is
horrible. But if there's anything good from this,
it would be hopefully the division within MAGA
world over Trump's endorsement of of Mehmet Oz